how we come to the awards for writing
those people upon whom so many other
performers depend
all the carts still will you please
to present the awards a lovely lady who
likes writers so much she married one
miss Deborah Carr
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
well as I've always believed the plays
the thing and the nominees for Best
Screenplay based on material from
another medium are Edward anhalt Beckett
Stanley Kubrick Peter George and Terry
southern for dr. Strangelove or how I
learned to stop worrying and love the
bomb bill gosh and Don dagradi for Mary
Poppins alan jay lerner for my fair lady
and micro-cap Aramis was over the Greek
and the winner is Edward M house Rebecca
nation very much I hope the television
audience shares the feeling that comes
from winning an award from a jury of
one's fellow craftsmen thank you to mr.
Hal Wallis and thank you to the Academy
the nominees for best story and
screenplay written directly for the
screen our story by SH Barnett
screenplay by Peter stone and Frank
collar for father goose story and
screenplay for Allen by
excuse me Allen by Allen Allen for a
hard day's night story by ordinate
Hampton screenplay by Rafael Hayes and
organ age Hampton for one potato two
potato story and screenplay by RJ
Scarpelli and mario monicelli for the
organizer story and screenplay by
example of no I am Newton Daniel
Boulanger and Philip de Braga
for that man from Rio and the winner is
SH Barnett Peter stone and Frank fall
off for father boots
my deepest thanks to Cary Grant who
keeps winning these things for other
people thank you
he just told my whole speech